what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends yep
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia
sistine and scarlett
i was gonna say and scarlett stallone
because we have her
back with us in the studio because
everyone loved our podcast her last time
and we had our mom on last week and we
decided let's keep it in the phone keep
it going
welcome back hey guys i'm back did you
miss me
apparently because you got an odd amount
of views
on your episode you guys are so welcome
scarlett i'm carrying the team
insulted i'm insulted do you really
think you are
i kind of do to be honest with you i
mean
look at the views well you better bring
your numbers don't lie baby
i mean i guess but just bring your a
game today
are you ready yeah i am all right we're
gonna kick you guys off with another
weekly update scarlett was just in l.a
for a whole week
yes i was i realized that i do have
friends back at home
since the move i was just sitting in
palm beach thinking
you know what i have friends i'm sitting
alone
friday nights why don't i just go back
to la
and my experience back in la was amazing
i miss it so much and i do want to come
home i do i do i i
realize that i've missed a whole senior
year and
making up with time with friends it
really does
justice oh i'm happy to see you i've
actually missed you a lot and we told
the viewers
last week or perhaps the week before two
weeks ago
that you just got accepted to college we
are very proud of you
thank you sophie and i and the unwaxed
family we congratulate you scarlett
thank you it's a big deal
it was yeah it's all those years of
education and schooling and everything
and it finally made up for it
i did where well all of us we were
taught to work really hard in school and
i think it really
paid off at the end yeah i'm so happy
with my results i'm excited to see you
thrive in college i feel like
you are made for college i am
i am made for college i'm not going to
tell say what college i'm going to
because i don't want to expose that to
tell the viewers that but
i am going to a really good college and
i'm very proud of i'm sorry i wish i i
wish i can say it i wish
but i'm excited because i get to now
know exactly what she's doing throughout
college and she can come to me for
college events yeah my sisters are going
to stalk me during
don't you my i have better things to do
than stalk you all day i'm not saying
that i said absolutely let's go to a
frat party
absolutely not i'm not gonna have my two
hot older sisters going to the party
taking attention away from me see i was
gonna dress as the mascot
you would have never known it was me you
would dress up as the mouse i would and
i would show it
uh speaking of creepy because you said
creepy man on plane i just thought of
an interaction that i had with a creepy
man recently
oh yeah you guys this is bad this is
actually really bad
and nothing like this has ever happened
to me before but i just sort of wanted
to bring it up
um not to freak anyone out but more just
to
always be aware of your surroundings and
always trust
your gut because i feel like your
intuition sometimes you'll try to talk
yourself out of it
and it ends up always being right let me
explain
i went on a walk the other day and i was
just had my headphones in
but then i noticed something that didn't
really sit right with me i saw this
young boy
who looked about eight years old he was
walking along the ocean by himself
i didn't see any parents around it
looked like he had lived in that
neighborhood because
it just looked that way okay and then i
see this
older man on a bike going by
stops in front of the kid and starts
talking and i felt like okay it could be
his
dad it could be somebody new
but just by the the young boy's
mannerisms of him
not really making eye contact and
continuing to walk
while trying to answer and be polite to
this old guy
it just didn't seem right so i stopped
and i just waited and i waited about a
minute and i was watching the
interaction and it just
progressively wasn't sitting more right
with me so
i approached the guy and i stare at him
saying hey [ __ ] i see you and i
know what's going on here
and it's not sitting well with me and he
drove away
he biked away and i go up to the kid and
i go
hi and i try to not come off as creepy
but i'm trying to be approachable and i
say hi did you know that man
and he said no and i said okay let me
walk you home and i walked him home and
i just felt
a disgusted by the whole situation
because you think
who knows what could have happened or
i've tried
obviously you don't want to think the
worst but in that case scenario i had to
never worse you never
know and i just felt like i wanted to
share the story because i wanted
everyone just to
always be aware of their surroundings
yeah and really take action
if you see something is not right follow
your gut
speak up and i'm really happy i did um
dad what did dad always tell us dta
don't trust anybody don't trust anyone
and
what was his boy scout code that he
always told us be prepared
or no oh oh you're right but that's not
what i meant to say
it's something like um if it happens if
it happens
just what what is it oh my god i know
this
if it could happen it will oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and i i honestly when i came home and
mom told me that this happened i am
it makes me so proud of you that you
really went for it because i think a lot
of people in these situations
it's one of those have you seen that
show called what would you do
where there's an uncomfortable situation
and then the guy pops out of nowhere
the guy's like yeah there's one i forgot
but he's always in a suit
like someone's being racist or someone's
being rude to uh staff or whatever it is
and you really get to see humans
interact with that and some of them
don't some of them avoid and
in that scenario that was a really tough
one because
you could have seen maybe that is that
but
worst best case scenario worst case
scenario it could have been his dad and
you would have found that out and it's
always better to be safe than sorry a
hundred percent
because what like what would happen if
you didn't go up to that little boy or
yeah i wouldn't have been able to sleep
at night just
be aware always speak up and
and if something doesn't sit right with
you make a change
and you could be saving a life if you do
so or you could be teaching someone a
new way
a new perspective if you call them out
on it 100 so i think you saved that
little boy
in some sort of way and maybe now he
knows
what to do for the future dta people
don't trust anyone and let's keep going
with this string of creepy people
um i had a once again
creepy stalker whoo go
sofia i'm so proud of you thank you
thank you guys so much
we love you i know what is it about
sophia take this award
and i'm so honored to be the one that
gets the creepiest dm's out of the group
but what is it about sophia that
attracts all these creepy men i don't
know
i really she's got a body audio
i knew that you are gonna say this i
knew it
okay so um i wanted to bring this up
because it really did this
actually really freaked me out and it
freaked her out as well when i told her
and it stressed my dad out as well
because it wasn't just
an alarming weird weirdo dm
it was one of those that you would see
in a horror film no you feel threatened
i felt very threatened i felt like i was
in scream
so it's really yeah i really know it's
so this
man um i don't usually go through my dms
but
now because of the situation that
happened if you guys listen to the last
story sophia's scariest stalker with the
whole
him coming onto campus i'm a lot more
hyper focused on
who's messaging me in that creepy sense
just to make sure that no one's actually
going to do something before i can catch
it
and i noticed this guy was constantly
sending messages saying
he is in the same area as i'm in all of
his stuff
sending photos and then he sent another
thankfully was like the last 20 cent was
i just walked outside your house and
i wanted to see if you wanted to hang
out like i saw your
window open and which my window is
always you know he said something
you should read a word for me i don't
have it but it was like i'm outside he
said
like he sent multiple before and he goes
i see i found
you i'm outside your house right now
like i see you in your window yeah
and i remember you telling me yeah that
made me feel so
sick to myself because it's not only
so threatening to just me it's
threatening to my entire family and i
found that
so it my stomach dropped and i didn't
know what to do like what do you do well
who knows if he's telling the children
yeah exactly who knows but what if he
was telling him
no no i know he's in the area because i
looked through his dms
our instagram page and he's like posting
the
walks we normally go on unfortunately
area there's nothing you can do really
because you're just a sitting duck he's
not on our property he was walking
around so i'm just sitting down
stop doing that you don't leave at least
get out of our dm's if you're over 40
get out of our dms or me
please assistant don't do this again
actually stop
it's so annoying and it freaks me out
freaks out she's gonna make a joke like
if you want to go to my dm's you could
do my dm that's how she
always said am i that predictable yes
you said that every single time i bring
up an overflow i wasn't gonna say that
if you're 35 okay if you're 35
and under you can go into the scene um
regardless moving forward
i actually had something really funny
happen to me the other day what
okay look and just on a high note for
our weekly update it's a very dark
weekly
yes so
i was walking around the i guess just
like
the town what would you say that area is
that there's like little restaurants and
shops
and i saw this cute guy and he was
wearing on the front he was just kind of
standing waiting i think for his uber or
something
and he had a d on the
front of his hoodie yeah and i was like
oh my god like perfect
i can just go up and start a
conversation because
my cousin went to duke and all this
stuff and i assumed duke university
so um i was like ooh cute duke college
educated so i walk up to him and i say
hey
my cousin went to duke too like really
great school like
what like did you go what year did you
graduate and his
car like pulls up and he doesn't even
say a word to me i don't know if i like
freaked him out
and i see on the back of his shirt it
says disneyland
the back of the shirt did say duke oh my
god that's so embarrassing
disneyland
it could go both ways he was pretty tall
he could have been at least a young
a young 27 year old or a 20 year old
or an 18 year old or an 18 year old i
hope barely passing please i hope you
but
guys i was so nervous you know when i
get nervous i talk
a lot yeah so i don't say i rambled
about duke and my cousin and how he went
and how she went
for like a good if count to 30 30
seconds straight
and then he doesn't say where he's like
oh yeah and it says disneyland that's oh
poor kid i know poor me i don't know
what's so fair
are you kidding me i mean he definitely
want to talk to you if you said you know
i know but
what's your favorite i love space
mountain i love disney and
the mata
no i won't go to disney world i already
don't like the land
how would i like the world because i
hate the land
she's like i don't want it to be bigger
um let's transition
you guys love our little bedtime story
segment
[Music]
okay so we are back with another round
of bedtime stories
i know sophia you sort of wanted to talk
about this one and i'll definitely chime
in with you oh i wanted to talk about
this one because
we had a mini argument and then you
brought up the fact that you used to do
this thing
that's right kind of obviously fixed our
fight because we started cracking up
about it but
it was one of those unlocked memories
yeah
i love those unlocked memories uh so
when sophia and i were younger
we used to fight a lot and i honestly
could not tell you today
what one one of those fights was even
about
no idea but they got to the point of
being physical like
and i remember i would always lose those
physical fights because i was just
so small so weak and tiny skinny and i
look like a green bean and sophie you
would just sit on me and it would
be all be over so if you were to chuck
something across through i went you
could throw
down but you know what you used to do
i'm unlocking more memories right now
sophia and i watched a lot of wwe
we used to love it oh so summerslam
summerslam i mean
the cave the money bag
that you would actually do the same
moves from
randy orton and the undertaker
john cena you would do those on me like
the arm barn
i mean the sniper i mean you did all of
those moves on me and i would just be
like bouncing off the walls but anyway
so we used to fight a lot as kids
and always when you'd fight and i feel
like a lot of
siblings can relate to this you always
go to either your mom or your dad
to determine who would win the fight oh
wait so we'd always go to our mom
because
she we just needed i don't know i feel
like she had the
she ran the house yeah if mom was if any
of us were in a fight and mom was on one
of our sides
that side would win that's why
automatically any side so sophia and i
always ask kids we would go up to our
mom and it would each state our case
and it was almost like a jury it wasn't
so sophia would go first
my mom goes to steen do not speak sophia
go
and sophie would have literally admitted
to stay in her case and then i would
have a minute to state my case
except what i would notice it literally
was cool
what i would notice a lot was sophia
would switch up the language of it
of the facts of the fight and it started
to piss me off and she was very
convincing
very convincing so i thought in my
little
15 year old brain you want to play dirty
i can get [ __ ] dirty i started to
secretly record our fights
so rude you guys that's so dirty how
dirty is that
every single fight she would turn on her
camera
or her little recording machine without
sophia knowing stop me knowing and then
i didn't realize but by the way she
didn't bring these tapes up
until much later like you didn't you
didn't use them and that's when i had a
bet with you
but when we were just fighting i would
record you
you'd say i never said that i'd play the
audio
no but no this was instant win i'm
telling you you should be a lawyer
no that's dead that's illegal i don't
know i want to be like 16 still does
that
i want to be a spy that'd be cool you'd
be good
i'd be a good hacker it's so annoying
because every time we ever get into an
argument now
sistine remembers everything you say
i have the worst memory and i will
forget everything
well that's a so she always wins that's
a cancer trait we uh
forgive but we never forget say for
example i'd make a bet with you i
remember this one time i made a bet with
you and you would say
okay if i don't have a boyfriend because
i would always give a [ __ ] about not
having a boyfriend
and you told me oh my god
i have a boyfriend six months from today
you are allowed to i'll be your butler
for a day
i'll let you push me in the pools all my
clothes on stupid [ __ ] like that
she wouldn't know that i would record
her
literally play that audio six months
from the day i don't know why i ever
actually agreed to
any of that because you didn't think i
would remember because it's a
i never actually thought you would take
it so seriously so see she would
be seriously if she says odds she's
saying ah she's saying um one to ten
what are you gonna do um if you lose
this go jump in the pool and then
scarlet and i are one of those people
like oh you don't actually have to do it
i know
that we're kind of killer with this
that's the most annoying if we say oh
what are the odds one through ten you go
do this do you know why you never do it
i'm about to unpack because
i can agree with me i will we would do
it you would never do it
never never every time we say a bet
sistine
you wouldn't actually follow through let
me tell you this right now sistine would
make me do
the craziest stuff when i was younger
she would say
stuff i don't even want to say because
it's so gross oh
what what did i make you do
oh i just even heard that on the audio
i did not make you do that and guess
what yeah you did i did
i did do it i remember i don't even want
to say it and i really hope you guys
did not hear it but like cece would tell
me to do
the craziest nasty things when i was
younger and i
as a little daredevil i would be like
okay yeah sure
you would be so rude be like why aren't
you doing it why aren't you doing it
yeah you have to do it you have to do it
eat this yes do that she thought she
could turn this story time against
i'm gonna play devil's advocate right
now
yes i'm a great convincer but there is
no gun to yourself
saying eat this do that you guys could
have just been like
well whatever we do whenever we do it to
you
you're like no no no because we just
want
because we want your questions why did
you do why did you listen because
no we do it because we make a bet and
we're like okay we're actually gonna
follow through
you don't follow through well anything
oh make a bet
right now on the show make a butt
if i'm trying to think what
whoever gets married first oh my god
it's so much longer
too talking about the long game okay
okay
um find
as i mean i think i know what you're
saying is there's things i want to say
but i feel like i shouldn't say on the
show because this thing is like that
hurts my feelings cut it like
cut it we'll cut it say it make a friend
oh i didn't do that
i wasn't gonna say that friend does not
actually last like a long time
this is not recording right what are you
talking about
this is i thought we were cutting it
this is garland no no it's not live
we're recording we're gonna cut it i i'm
never having you back on the show
wow that was cruel i'm crying
on the inside but staying cool on the
outside
she has oh my gosh
should i go this is really awkward yeah
you know um sophia what was your bet
my thought was just to get another hot
gym guy number i could do that
you can do that okay we're gonna move on
that was a story time god everyone says
i mean that
was cool wait we can cut that stone cold
scarlet stallone
cold cold cold cold
it's okay it's fine it's fine i'm fine
so let's move on i can admit that i was
not a cute kid when i was younger when i
say not cute i mean
not cute and sistine agrees with me
because
i i made this tick stock and you know
how i really realized you had a girl
grow up grow up grow up same thing
same thing tomato tomato is we made that
tick tock trend
where oh i made it for everyone where
you get old photos of yourself from when
you're younger
and then you go and then all of a sudden
all these like who made nine
i made all of yours because i wanted to
really see the contrast between that and
now
i made it for everybody and yours was
the hardest scarlet because you actually
were a cute kid
you were sistina no not really but
since like baby momo and i looked like
what was it that everyone called me
ugly buddy ugly you guys i sophia and i
talk about this all the time
i am terrified for the day that
people start to pull up archived
pictures of us from when we were younger
and compare them to what we look like
today because it literally looks like
we got a face transplant i just feel
like my
face i didn't actually grow into it
until i was about 20.
like i like nothing makes sense and it
literally looks like
we got entirely new faces yeah it does
we were so
ugly you know there's like face after i
looked like a sly
we'll start there yeah that's brutal
that's brutal that is brutal i never was
like your dad's handsome but
a female version of sly is not not
cute not cute it's not cute i mean
sophia scarlett says that
she was an ugly kid yeah maybe for a
year
you had braces no i always talk about
how they grow into myself until really
like later yeah but you were always tall
and lean and had beautiful hair
and always had a lot of friends like you
were never
awkward and ugly sofia would wear
things and cut our hair a certain way
and and do things that were awkward and
ugly
i cut bangs in high school myself i want
to just say this before we even get more
into it
we're not bringing this up because we
want compliments but i just want to
say that a lot of people come up to us
and say oh my god you have it all
figured out like you have your makeup
figured out your hair your clothes
your everything you guys they just
figured it out they just got it
yes we just figured it out and i still
think i am figuring out because
i just remembered that oh god unlocking
memories
this happened like last week one of the
the guy i was talking to
not anymore um he said he went through
my instagram he just said he was like
stalking it we're just gonna run over
that last
just you're just gonna fast forward i'm
just gonna there's a little
in the road we just keep going oh so
it's a bump in the road no it wasn't a
bump of the road it was just like a
little like like a pothole like a bullet
pool oh that's worse
the cars are fine can you guys get to
the point what my point was was that
he was going through my instagram and he
was like you definitely had a glow up
from like last year this year and i
thought of my head
let me pause he said you had a glow up
from last year to this year
he said he went through all my photos
and then he said he's like oh
you know more recently i've seen you've
gone like better looking
like a glow up and i was thinking in my
head like last year i thought i was
good pretty good i was looking at old
photos i was like oh you know my hair
looked great
i was like i sometimes think i look
better back then you do yeah
apparently i did not but why i'm just
saying it's like you guys
i i mean i can just really quick tell
you what i looked like back then in one
year i was cracking up with cysteine i'm
in scarlet and is in middle school
i got braces i got bangs
i got glasses and acne
all in one year and that continued on
for a while
and when i say glasses i mean grease
lightning
50s pointed up glasses my braces my
braces
were colored with green oh god
yellow my personal favorite orange no no
no sophie didn't choose the white bands
you know the rubber bands you put on
your braces no she chose orange should
people should do that i'll do you one
better
yeah sofia walked into middle school
looking like
a bootleg motley crew like we were we
looked like the character from big mouth
the the [ __ ] up uh hormone monster
like what are you gonna do
about it you do it so well do it
do it dude you got it no i can't do it
sophia i can't
do it guys
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay so sophia you look like ugly buddy
yes i thought
i looked so cute with full on not cute
side bangs but like the thick cut
yeah like like sick cut i had
animal print knee socks every day that
went up
past my knee i wore converse with two
different color neon laces
i to do one better my dad took me to
thailand
and decided to go to some village where
the women that lived in the village cut
off all my hair
knee socks side bangs and sophie and i
weren't
playing the cool sports we were playing
shot put
shotgun shot put okay so steve said i
was bad at high jump
we did a high job i was actually really
good at high jumping you
were so bad i remember you would cry oh
my god
you guys sophia would do high jump but
we'd have these competitions um
in in middle school and she couldn't i
don't know why but like you just
couldn't jump that high
like you've got a lot of force going
into it but your feet wouldn't leave the
ground
and you would land on your back on the
pole and cry every day every time
but not only that sometimes i'd miss the
mark and i'd hit the
thing holding the pull up the like oh
the hard
let me go into high school i'm still not
done with i still no i i have another
high school thing that you were gonna
laugh you laughed at
i did this in college i don't know why i
wore a flash drive around my neck like
it was an accessory for years
and i kept it as i thought i was really
okay
so you know like sometimes you watch
like those vampire movies and you're
like i'm gonna put like two dots just
like mysterious and
all that stuff so my thing was i wanted
to be different and so i wore a
flashlight of all my little short
stories about werewolves that right
my poetry my lyrics i'd be the kid in
the yard like sticking it into my
computer singing like
he loves me like the flowers on his
doorstep
like literally trying to be showing you
never so unique she never
left without a flash drive around her a
lanyard
i never knew what was in that flash
drive i'm actually surprised
oh so then let's get to high school i'm
still awkward as [ __ ]
in high school uh i played volleyball
except
i couldn't even fill out the spandex no
because i had
negative body yeah so i had baggy
spandex
and uh let's see what else oh uh oh no
no your makeup
oh your makeup my god the eyeliner
under sister can i say eyes raccoon
house no no no no i wish it was as good
as amy oil
no raccoon under eyes let me explain i
don't know where she took that pencil
i was taking this [ __ ] on from seventh
grade all throughout high school
i would never wear that much makeup to a
club today i
smokey eye dark brown smokey eye every
day just to look older
looked so much worse you know moral of
the story y'all
um we are not cute what is the moral
moral of the story is that i'm glad
we weren't the hottest little things
growing up honestly because it has
no for me personally i think it was
better because
i i uh
it wasn't that good actually so yeah i'm
trying to make it possible there's
nothing positive about it i hated it
i played pokemon behind a greenhouse
every day actually positive
positive we have funny photos to look
back on
yeah there we go but i'm also terrified
that later on people are going to pull
up those images
before and afters what did they do to
their it's not fair
i feel bad honestly when they do those
before and afters on like celeb face and
those apps on instagram
because people do look different i i so
agree with that i
feel so bad because your face does
change as you get older you lose baby
fat on your face
yeah so i i agree makeup is done
everyone's like oh she got so much
plastic surgery
no maybe her face just like developed or
maybe she did get plastic surgery
honestly the day we is it now i'm
looking at it from the glass half full
if we make it on celeb face does that
mean we made it
i think so that's the level of fame i
want to get to
that's a little famous to be trashed on
before and afters
should we just keep [ __ ] on
ourselves so
sophia scarlett and i are about to out
ourselves so hard
i recently find out that the people that
i'm talking to the
suitors if you will listen to the
podcast
and they tell me that they listen and
then they quote me on certain things and
i know this next topic that we're about
to discuss is
really going to bite us in the ass later
because
because they're going to hear it
whatever we want to talk about flirting
and we want to talk about flirting 101
and we're not here to give you guys
flirting advice because i would say that
we are no connoisseurs
of flirting whatsoever but we thought
it'd be funny
for each of us to share how we approach
flirting no but they could take
something from it because
i would say my odds of getting the
number
are like a good 50 50. so try one of our
methods
you right good i'll paint this how about
i paint a scenario for us
and then each of us describe what we
would do
yeah in that scenario all right it's
pre-covered
give me a little instance we're in a
club
we're at a bar and it's crowded it's
packed
you're looking cute you got a nice
little dress on hair donna you got a
little drink
you got a little drink in your hand
you're feeling tipsy oh my god i'm
dancing still but not buzz
just really getting into it yes keep
going i've been just waiting
close your eyes right you see this
really cute guy from across the bar
he's with his friends but you know he's
dancing he's having a good time
action sophia what are you doing all
right
everyone calls me out about this because
when i see a cute guy i don't know
what happens to the chemicals in my
brain but i
become a statue so
i and i have a staring problem so i will
stare at the guy
intensely for a while and get him to
notice that i'm staring at him
it's like i want him to know that i'm
interested i'm checking him out so i
will
almost burn holes in the back of his
head i would like to interject
the look you give isn't so much sexual
it's more like
creepy it's like more i'm staring like
i'm gonna attack you like a cannibal
yeah yeah it's animalistic it's not
animals
yeah it's not hot and thing is in my
head i'm thinking it's hot
so but because this is the problem is
that when i notice a guy's
over here to my right or left whatever
it is i'm talking to either
seen scarlet or a friend i'm genuinely
not paying attention to what they're
saying and they know that
yep they can tell my demeanor is
different my because i'm normally a good
conversationalist when i'm in it i'm in
it
but when there's some guy on the right i
am focused on
posing standing up straight trying to
suck in the chest and sucking them
tits out tits out and also like giving
him the side eye so
finally hopefully he notices and i'll
either go over to him or he comes over
to me i don't know
i i have done the whole like approach
right off the bat like trying to make a
joke
and when i talk to someone i
automatically make jokes about
everything i don't necessarily always
tease them like sometimes i'll play a
little bit like give them [ __ ] back and
forth
it'll be a little sass but and that's
more if i have tequila
why i like girls sweet i like the sass i
like this i need a little sass but
always making it a joke and sometimes i
feel like the guys get overwhelmed
because
i am just non-stop talking
that's my problems i almost don't i have
a habit of that too yeah
um but yeah it's almost like a million
miles a minute and then you're like
what did we even yeah we even talked
about what was the confidence and then
finally
hit the home stretch i'm touching their
arms touching the chest touching the
face
yeah i give them like a hahaha laugh at
everything they're saying so
are you getting the digits now later
when you get the number uh that called
that conversation i end up like either
he'll i normally wait for the guy
to ask for my number because to be
honest i got a slightly different option
because i don't i like to also make the
decision later on if i get his number
if i want to actually text him okay i
have
a few overlapping things that i like to
do as well same scenario same scenario
you're at a bar
i'm at the bottom white wine i give eyes
you know but not uh serial killer eyes
like sophia does
i try to look approachable because i've
found that a lot of people say
i have really bad resting [ __ ] face so
immediately i'm trying to soften my face
because i've been told i look like a see
you next tuesday and then they're like
oh wait you're actually a lot nicer than
you come off so i'll try to you know
be approachable looking right and
normally i'll try to find an excuse to
walk up to them
and you know accidentally rub up against
them or if i'm trying to pass them i'll
be like oh excuse me and like i'm not
going to shoulder check the guy but
enough to to make some sort of brush
against each other
you know you could whatever you're into
so then i'll try to introduce myself
first i feel like that shows some sort
of dominance some confidence
as well like i'm sistine what's your
name and then shake their hand
firm hand grip too don't no dainty wet
fish it is flowering
grabbing on hard yes and then right
after that
right after they introduce themselves
back
i say you smell good i always say that
right away guys love that
key but what if they what if they smell
bad they don't give a [ __ ]
normally they don't they have clone on
yeah so
they smell good immediately that's
number one number two
like whoa whoa double confidence right
after that i'll try to make some small
talk i like to do what you do sophia
throw a little dig at them because they
always remember the girl
that was a bit smart yeah a little sassy
as opposed to the one that was just
predictable i guess you could say
uh for example a guy the other day told
me he was 6'3
he casually threw in the conversation
that he was 6'3
and i said am i supposed to be impressed
he was like oh no i'm just i'm just
saying like that's so rude
but it's cheeky it's cheeky but he'll
always remember that
so then this is the final key it's
pivotal
as you're about to leave the
conversation
whether you got the number or not you
ask them what their name is again
it shows that you really don't care that
much
and you weren't paying that much
attention to him that way he's going to
be like
wait why wasn't she listening as
intently as i was
guys like it if you're if you're a
little bit harder to get and you're not
so
uh i am so bad with names i actually do
forget that
that's true because i realized two
things being going and there's two ways
you can go about it going in with
confidence and being like my name's
steve bubba
what's your name again you leave exactly
but also
even if you like the guy and you're not
having a full-blown conversation if you
say
one thing that's kind of like i don't
know i remember i met this guy and i
said
oh you lost your shot and i walked away
even if we hadn't had a full
conversation just the pure fact that i
rejected him right off the bat that's my
point so ask them their name again
in your head you're thinking i don't
care i wasn't listening
and then you say okay i'll see you
around chad
chad whatever his name is good name and
then leave walk away
if he doesn't come up to you again after
that then
next move on from that guy i'm like a
combination of both of you
i'm so rude but like if any guy plays
along with that
and like is just as like cheeky
and kind of like they can take my [ __ ]
i don't think you're rude at all right
what i've never you've never seen me
really
in action before all i know is you are
too scared to approach them and you just
giggle from the back
right scarlett that's not me flirting
that's not me flirting you flirting
oh my god literally you having to be
pushed to talk to someone why are you
kidding yourself but what if i don't
have anyone and i'm actually flirting
with the guy
then and there so i'm not in the back
getting the whole talk is a point
you are always giggling charlotte has
like a little school girl school girl so
you could be a good
chat okay yeah but that's before the
flirt
when i'm flirting with them i don't know
like you're missing the whole beginning
we talked about the approach to it
your approach is standing in the back
and giggling oh i'm i'm talking about me
actually talking to the guy
does it even get there yeah i swear it
gets there i swear
yesterday we were at the beach and there
were a bunch of cute guys and sistine
was like let's go walk
to the water and you said no 100 every
time
i wasn't going i said i walked to the
water i just like ran back really
quickly so there there lies the problem
okay
um we're gonna move on to our favorite
segment the unsolicited advice segment
okay someone wrote this in there is no
question in it but i just had
to read it to show my appreciation
for this listener this person wrote in
does sistine listen to girl in red which
i'm assuming is
in erotica thank you for the suggestion
good suggestion
he said or even like half because i want
to wife her up and live in a cottage
type of tree house in the woods
with her and be fairies or something
like that i'll even let her have a
ratatouille themed wedding
and we can watch it every night if she
wants
see sophia i
love that thank you
you want to live in a tree house in the
woods no i don't want to
do that i'm just saying but anyway i
loved this because
he paid attention or she
or she paid attention to detail and
i'm down to move with you just let me
know when time and play i just thought
about this right now i was thinking
about
a ratatouille themed wedding and to be
honest
if i if it's the better version that i'm
thinking of not underground with a bunch
of rats in a sewage
area right it's in paris hello
um but so great food beautiful ambiance
and a famous rat is cooking your dinner
but obviously has clean hands
so gross pause pause don't be rude
you're being what that's gross a rat
cooking or dinner
yes um if it's better than rat it's
all your wedding you're gonna have rats
cooking it's better than your little rat
hands cooking my dinner
i don't think that's remy the
ratatouille wait did you
know a ratatouille cake
that they have a ratatouille roller
coaster ride coming
see i do not care it better not be at
disneyland
you don't care i like the movie actually
rather chewy to me is harry potter to
you
oh but harry potter
is so much more superior it's so
assisting you cannot compare
you hate potter you can't compare to
remy the rat from ratatouille
one red coin cook the other one can do
spells i'm sorry
to each their own to each their own
anyone can
cook anyone can cook okay read the next
question
so the next question is actually
specifically for scarlet and we saw this
um a couple i think it was last month
and now we have her back on so why not
have her just answer it
it's from gracie t i love your podcast i
loved your most recent podcast girl it
should definitely be a regular
and i loved your new story very funny i
have two questions
first being if scarlett is willing to
talk about it which
she is i am um i am very curious to hear
how her breakup went
three years is a long time and i really
hope it wasn't too bad
second being how do you get over a guy
once again i really love your podcast
and your sound quality is crazy
as well i hope the sound quality is
making you proud today this question
actually just started making my
my heart like start pounding a little
faster i don't know because it's like
it's a weird topic i i mean it's it's a
sensitive topic but
um everyone deals with breakups
differently because everyone has
different relationships so i wasn't only
losing my boyfriend i was also losing
like my best friend oh my god i'm
getting emotional
um oh that's okay um
i oh my god stop looking at me like this
by the way this is on wax um i know it's
unboxed but i don't like
showing this okay it's good to be home
like i grew up
having him in my life and he was a huge
part of it
and having him oh my god do you want me
to wait
let me know you know what scarlett
you're
this question is a very very hard
question to answer it's
when you especially you're only 18 years
old three years of your life is a long
time especially for someone that
is a great guy like him and there was no
problem he's not a bad person
i also think that you
were gonna be okay when you came on the
show to talk about this i was so
okay i was so prepared and then all
right and i just started tweaking
um i mean i think maybe that but like my
my piece of advice
for anything is my piece of advice for
anything
is after a breakup it is so sensitive
going out of it don't communicate with
each other right away
i've been wanting to reach out to him so
there's been so many times where i
wanted to reach out to him but
i don't think he's ready and i'm going
to respect his time because
no matter what in a relationship you're
not together anymore
so you have to learn how to live without
each other you
that's why you shouldn't be hey how are
you how is the
like you can't text him the next day how
hey i'm just checking in on you no
you have to learn to live by yourself
you have to learn i was with him
since i was 16 years old so he was a
very
oh oh my god i'll say this i remember
when scarlett you would come up to me
and you kept saying
should i text him can i text him is it
the right time and
i always talk to you out of it and maybe
that wasn't
what you wanted to do or maybe that
wasn't what he wanted as well but
because i maybe he doesn't want to keep
trying to tell you
respect his timeline even if you're
ready to talk to him doesn't mean that
he is
and you obviously loved this person and
you still really care about this person
and
yeah he needs the time to also mourn the
loss of the relationship
i i completely get it because i went
through the same thing like two years
ago and i was with someone for two years
and
i mean as you can see this is obviously
not
a old breakup like i could be able to
talk about my ex and not
get emotional about it but i definitely
wasn't able to do that
two years ago and so i mean scarlett
obviously you can see like you're you're
moving on i got we
i i
haven't cried about him or anything all
i know is that
the way to get over someone too is
don't mourn for so long and
like consistently drag on that sad
emotion
you he's still there she's still there
they're not going anywhere and if it's
meant to be they'll come back
but all i did was i
yes i did cry for like two days straight
i had my family with me they supported
me
but i also cried i listened to
lana del rey and i got over it and i
picked myself up
and i kept moving forward you maybe
thought you were ready to talk to him a
few days ago or
a few weeks ago i just realized i'm not
and you realize you're not and that's
okay too
i do think the one important thing is
when you are getting over a breakup
is you need to just be super honest by
your feelings i do this and we all do
this is
we will cry for a bit and then we'll go
for the next month saying
i am fine i am fine i am fine and then
one photo
one talk one conversation triggers you
and you just know you're not fine and
i think that is a way to start moving
forward is when you
are able to have these conversations
with sistine i just because
maybe you're you'll have a crush on
someone or you're hanging out with your
friends a ton
those are just distractions and truly
moving on does
take time even you know if you're out
there and you're in a relationship that
is
terrible and toxic and you know it's not
good for you those are equally just as
hard
sometimes if not harder to get over it
yeah you're not going to hate them for
your only emotion that is just love it's
just the worst part is like
we didn't end on a bad note we didn't
there was no that we didn't end
poorly or anything i'm just saying any
of us have ever really ended
horribly yeah because i i'm that person
that hates ending on bad notes with
anyone that i love and that's important
to me and that's why i think
you know you're still young and there's
still time and i think you guys are
going to be
incredible friends down the line just
right now it's too premature
but i think it's important and i'm
really happy you're talking about it me
too i'm
happy you're open and vulnerable on the
podcast today yeah
thank you so much um so just to
reiterate
if you guys want to submit more
questions and maybe get cystenide to
tear up a little bit
go to apple podcast give us the five
stars and
write a review and write your question
and we will definitely come around to it
yeah please i actually want to cry
that'd be exciting me too yeah you guys
ever cried on this
no well you almost made me cry today
with that friend comment
well thank you guys so much for coming
back to unwax we are here every single
tuesday and if you want us to bring back
scope which we definitely probably will
let us know thank you guys and we will
see you soon we love you
bye from all of us here at the show
thanks for staying on wax
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts
at sophia stallone and at sistine
stallone and be sure to follow the show
at unwax podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week